foreign
[Music]
flights coming from the Dominican
Republic
which is a source control for narcotics
especially cocaine
platform
you don't know how a drug trafficker
looks like
they use all people young people the
more people you stop the better chance
you have to get something
hi
you have your passport
and you're coming from Santiago Santo
Domingo
um
your flight's not in here it's upstairs
okay follow this is a young kid kind of
lost he didn't know where to go now for
his connecting flight he didn't want to
make any eye contact I found that
strange
anybody asked you to put anything in
your bag
everything is yours
okay so how long you were in the
Dominican Republic
and what do you do here you go to school
work
so the school you know it's open so you
stay there for a whole month what
happened with that oh right now I'm
actually too small but uh
are you okay
you're too jumpy what's going on
so how old are you now
[Music]
who pay for your ticket
for your plane ticket
your brother and North Carolina or where
oh in Jackson California
Washington California
have you ever been in California
I just came from California
okay you came from California going to
the Dominican Republic
yeah come pay attention
so you came from California here and
then Dominican Republic
[Music]
and what is the plan what are you gonna
do now
okay
what is this Xbox
why are you going on Xbox
can you try that for me
let me know
this is something that we always gotta
check because we have found drugs inside
our Xboxes speakers Electronics radio
TVs any item so you took the Xbox
right
foreign
let's see what we get with this one
this is narrow he's been my partner for
the last five years we're here at the
mail facility and we're just looking for
narcotics
we're looking for heroin ecstasy
fantennial marijuana and lately we've
been getting a lot of cocaine if there's
odor is gonna find it
there's something there huh
piece of learning to the package
in this box for coming from Panama
but I don't
I gotta learn on the box can you check
it out please you got it bro
this one was going to Georgia
I'm gonna run it through the X-ray and
take a look
and we'll see what's going on
yep there's definitely something wrong
with that box
now covers the fun part we had to open
the box
[Music]
brand new clothes it looks like the gift
or something but maybe that's just to
try to convince us that it's good
but we'll check it out maybe it's in the
Box the only way to tell is cutting it
or probing it
see if I can get under here
[Music]
that's glued really good
this is definitely something wrong those
boxes are unusually glued like this
[Music]
there we go it's loaded around the
perimeter it's got something concealed
inside the flaps of the box it could be
any drug
it's not a lot right here but it'll
light up
[Music]
that blue stuff is detergent
you can smell it this is mascular
chemical odor the narcotics
it's fortunate the canine has a really
good scent so for him obviously it
didn't work
and the X-ray machine doesn't care about
smells it doesn't look very you know
we have eight packages total go test it
real quick
we're gonna use a thermal scientific
Gemini and it'll send a laser beam
through the material
it'll tell me what it is
oh
it's cocaine hydrochloride
278.4 grams a little over a quarter of a
kilo
now we're going to do a seizure report
or document everything where it's coming
from who it was going to we're going to
call HSI maybe do a controlled delivery
or maybe it ends here and we just season
narcotics and it gets destroyed they're
pretty good at it they put brand new
clothes they send you the receipts so
you think it's a legitimate purchase
it was a good try they get an A for
effort
it just didn't work out for them
thank you
foreign
everything's okay that's good okay so
it's nothing in there you can put it
away
hang out here I'll be back I'm gonna
check the chicken
we took the bags everything was clean
but I trust my instinct
he told me this brother came for his
ticket and I would like to verify all
the information that is possible
he said he went from California they are
but now he's gonna go to North Carolina
if you say a month come on
foreign
was purchased by home
address
is North Carolina
that's probably his brother yeah all
right
I'll do some research about his flight
and everything was okay
all right let's put everything away
the back was negative the Xbox was
negative so he's good to go for me
when you go out the door make a left and
then we're gonna go upstairs all right
have a good day
some people they're nervous to be
nervous
so I guess we gotta move on
yes
[Music]
yes
all right so we got information that a
large quantity of methamphetamine was
smuggled from Mexico and has come to a
local Stash House and has possibly been
distributed from this location
so what we're going to do today is we're
going to do some physical surveillance
on that Target location see what kind of
activity is going on in the house we did
start doing surveillance three or four
days ago on this residence and we've
seen somebody moving back and forth was
he driving he was driving a black pickup
truck
we do believe he's a drug dealer but we
don't have that probable cause to kick
his door right now hopefully if
everything goes well we'll be able to do
a search warrant inside the house and
take off this large quantity of drugs so
that's it ready to roll ready to roll
for your check loud and clear
I'm gonna go ahead and do a drive-by and
see if I can see any other cars that we
haven't seen before see any other people
moving out see the activities of our
main target just to kind of get a feel
of a pattern
so just beyond this White House
and this is what we believe to be the
Stash House
he's got a light blue door so it's very
easy to identify
all right so we're gonna drive by it
[Music]
we think that this bulk low to
methamphetamine is probably sitting in
this house hopefully we'll see some kind
of deal go down where these drugs are
being exchanged
[Music]
thank you
we're gonna run all these boxes
through the mail facility we get
narcotics every day
you name it we've seen it loaded
sneakers coffee beans radios hard drives
electronic equipment
nothing surprises anymore it's like
every day you get something new
this one was a negative definitely not
narcotics
that doesn't look good
it says Sporting Goods equipment and two
fans I don't see the reason to send fans
they got them everywhere
this package was coming from a source
country Trinidad and Tobago and it's
going to a demand country Australia
the value is very high over there for
any type of narcotic
something doesn't look right
seems like cheap plastic but in the
image it looks too thick
the only way to really look if you don't
like the image you take a quick peek
inside
see that right there
that's not supposed to be there that's
why it looks thicker in the X-Men
machine
they usually glue them in and they're
not hard to pop off
try to see if we can peel back a little
bit of it so we can see what's under it
and whatever it is it's wrapped in
aluminum foil
no
see
it's loaded you can see that it's white
I'll test it real quick
broom with some pink above it it's hard
to see but it's there it's positive it's
cocaine
we have 806.4 grams
I can tell you what it's gonna go for
now nothing one's pretty good guys
foreign
go ahead and tell your passenger we're
gonna take her to a private room and I'm
gonna head up there
we have a female passenger coming now
from the Caribbean we'll start with this
one
one of the officers randomly select her
she had a short trip she went for a few
days but she had a huge bag with her
and I want to see why the back is so big
what she has in there
check everything
you gotta fill every panel the size
bottom
can I see The Purge
that was so heavy
something else in here
oh wow surprise
what is this
something was inside behind the line and
of the purse a package on each side of
the bag
give me the test kid
remains theater there we're gonna test
what you bring in here
foreign
[Music]
it's just an advocate or function
just in case a nightmare
well this is reality
1.167
what
was it in the liner yeah yours
you understand you were transporting
narcotics into the United States
so at this point the more you give me
the better this is going to go for you
so do whatever you kind of help yourself
[Music]
in position with an eye on the target
door
all right Temple the target left what we
believe to be the stash house probably
about an hour ago but we didn't have
enough people up here at the time to
follow him I was able to see him walk
out and he didn't have anything in his
hands so he may be running some errands
but we don't know
our Target's driving a black Dodge Ram
pickup truck
so now it's just a waiting game
oh this might be good
[Music]
The Target just arrived back
oh yeah he's sitting in his black truck
oh he's moving right now
he's out of the truck
he's got a small bag
he's looking around quite a bit
that could be money that looks boxy kind
of like if you have a stack of cash who
knows it's gonna have to be something
certain to find the right amount of
probable cause to take it down
the bag he had in his hand when he went
into the Target locations so to me that
looks like he went and picked up some
cash from somewhere
and then we've got a train
it's about to be out of my view
I have a train
that decided to stop for some reason
right in front of me
yeah copy them
coming out of the house can't tell what
he's got in his hands
you still got eyes on them no I could
barely see under the train
every cabin the bags could be some math
ready to go
he's in the truck
he's backing out I turn the roll over
there
a little bit oh shoot he's moving right
now
he may be going to a drug deal and I am
blocked
oh he's moving right now we got a
possible drug dealer with possibly the
drugs in this car and I am blocked come
on train
I'm awesome
he might be going through the
neighborhood I'm gonna try to get in
front of him
all right let's see
yeah right here
so that's him right there black Dodge
Ram
yeah I just met him at the intersection
going northbound so our Target pulled
out and we've got some guys that are
following him right now we're gonna try
to catch up to him
yeah he just turned left into the
shopping park
ing right now
all right let's get in behind them
I just don't want to get too close
[Music]
all right so the target's vehicle is
parked in front of that thrift store so
he's just sitting in his truck out in
the middle of the parking lot right now
his truck's right there
facing away from us basically
more speculating what he's actually
doing here but with his mannerisms as
far as parking way out from the store
not going in that's very suspicious
activity kind of makes you think that
he's waiting on somebody to show up
which would be great if he drops that
bag to somebody and we can get that guy
taken off down the road then we're going
to have our probable cause to get in
that house
thank you
right here
I know you're upset so we're gonna make
him as comfortable as we possibly can
I'm gonna release one hand okay
most people once again
once again we're genuine some are just
trying to make people feel bad
hit some tissues
we have kids right
have one is three
I know it's hard but you gotta just try
and relax at this point you just help
yourself okay
mistakes happen now you fix them
who gave you the purse
how do you know
is I see a boyfriend or just a friend
um
what's his name
[Music]
what's his last name
you don't know his last name
but you've known him for years
right
um who are you supposed to give this to
all right listen listen an agent's gonna
come here
right they're gonna ask you the same
questions you got to try real hard to
remember his last name
it's up to you whether you want to
cooperate or not okay
we've contacted HSI they'll do some
further questioning on her and see if we
can get some other information for
anyone that might be connected
[Music]
[Music]
his truck
all right so in the gold 4Runner pulled
up next to our Target
the driver getting out
all right so what guy he's getting his
truck getting his truck all right he's
uh in the truck right now white male
from the gold vehicle got in the
passenger seat of our
Dodge Ram and he's meeting with our
Target right now
did y'all see anything in the driver's
hand of the Forerunner open up the
passenger side door and throw something
in a consumer it wasn't when you see an
item come from one vehicle and go to the
other vehicle most people would be able
to determine that that's possibly a drug
deal that just occurred
before working out
Target vehicle leaving them
all right copy we will focus on this
gold Forerunner
all right the vehicle is headed towards
the exit
[Music]
here we go
I'm the driver to the Forerunner threw
something in his back passenger seat and
we're following him North right now he's
hitting 75 Southbound
all right entrance
and copy them
Temple waiting to make contact
Georgia State Patrol guy getting on to
help us with the traffic stop
right here on the left
windows
all right here we go
and blue lights are on here
[Music]
foreign
GSP is deploying the canine on the
Forerunner they're doing a search of the
vehicle right now
all right here we go
hey will you grab that Peg I won't take
it to the bag and put it out on the back
of the corner
[Music]
thank you
there's the bag
that's the same bag that came out of the
house
this came from our guy
the bag is loaded
so we got math
there's a gun appears to be a Glock
probably a couple grand in cash he had a
set of scales
hello
apparently our guy in the Dodge been
stressing out barely on the phone about
something it's possible the gold
Forerunner got a text off to him saying
hey dude I just got pulled over by the
police you need to go ahead and secure
him and the location if he spooked that
much there is the possibility that he
could start flushing everything that's
in that house yeah copy them all right
all right bro bye bye
so we're close to a thousand grams in
just one bag so we're looking at two
kilos of methamphetamine
we're looking at about 10 grand
let's throw this in the back of my van
all right they got them guys yeah
copy our guys just detained the guy
driving the black Dodge that delivered
the meth so it's a great day so far but
we just keep growing next we're gonna
try to move into getting a search
warrant from the house that we know it
came from I would venture to say that
there's going to be a lot more meth in
that address so we're going to continue
the investigation from here
foreign
drugs United States that are worth a
very good amount of money willingly or
unwillingly or no knowledge or knowledge
it doesn't change anything right now
we're gonna talk okay
the main focus right now is to see if
she's telling us as much as she does
know because she obviously knows the
main guy
I know your birthday was yesterday did
you go down for a birthday trip or what
yeah what did you do when you were down
there you know I went out to eat we went
to some parties
pictures on your birthday trip
down there no
no did you have a hotel right in the
state when you went down there
no I stayed with him
we'll go paid for your ticket
did you find that weird
um
I felt
was trying to court me again
so you went down there with the purpose
of celebrating your birthday with him
and you don't remember his last name
guy for a good period of time that's
like a first date thing hey what's your
name this is my name yes that is true
that's hard for us to believe
did he tell you what was in the purse or
what it was for no never told me all he
told me was that it was for his friend's
mom and you don't remember what friend's
mom she did not he never told me like
the friend's name or anything he never
told foreign
let me explain kind of how this this is
going right like you're in a very bad
situation you have a good job and you
have a kid but he took advantage of you
whether he played on your love or he
played on your vulnerabilities you
basically set you up because you took
all the risk and right now you're doing
a lot of protecting of him because you
don't want to get him in trouble but
remember who ultimately got you in
trouble you have to start being honest
with us
is there anything you want to tell us
that you want to change or like hey I
remember his last name now or anything
like that
[Music]
is there anything you want to tell us
like hey I remember his last name now or
anything like that
I believe he told me maybe in the
beginning but like I can't say it so
what did he tell you I think
all right
so was he gonna pay you for this trip no
he never talked about money he never
talked about anything did he tell you
what was in the purse or what it was for
no never told me all he told me was that
it was for his friend's mom
you have to have some knowledge because
you have to know what risk is involved I
I don't I never even touched the bag I
saw it did I question it no should I
have I I guess I don't know I don't
I saw nothing notes that I haven't
ever think he would
but you're in that situation and that's
super don't even know I understand that
do you have any pictures
no text messages
[Music]
yeah that's him okay
[Music]
you trust me I'm not holding anything
back we can text him right now and tell
me what to tell him so you can hear
whatever you need to see I don't even
care
like I have nothing to do with this like
I wanted jeopardize
I understand I think myself just take a
deep breath take a deep breath
typical passengers like this that are
not told a lot she is cooperating with
us and so we're gonna go for it from
there
all right we're gonna call the
prosecutors and we're gonna finish our
paperwork do you have any questions real
quick
okay
come follow us
as now we've gotten most that we could
get out of her we'll still process her
and we're going to have a discussion and
make a final decision whether we
prosecute
but different things she told us and
other leads we can follow down the
further the case
the United States stands ready
particularly in the area of law
enforcement in the fight against
Wildlife trafficking
trafficking says we value trinkets more
than we value these magnificent animals
in the wild
we will stop the poachers we will stop
the profits to address this
transnational threat
we're on the way to uh air cargo
warehouse in Miami we just got a call
from the senior Wildlife inspector with
U.S fish and wildlife service the
shipment we're going to look at is
coming from South America and it's going
to a country in Asia
this is a common tripping route for a
lot of smuggled wildlife and the
Importer has had a previous violation so
we just want to go check the equipment
and see if what it is
[Music]
right here yeah we got an alert of a
possible shipment containing uh illegal
Seafood products this is that
we have a total of 18 boxes so we're
gonna check to make sure that everything
is in compliance uh and let's see what
we get
foreign let's take a look
sea cucumbers fish bladders in this case
the species on the shipment we don't
regulate it this bus is good to go
with a try open another box
oh wow
wow
we got sharp fins
I've been checking this type of
commodity for the past two or three
years and in order to trade shark fins
between countries you need a special
permit
at a quick glance we have three species
two of them most likely in violation
so let's see if they have any
documentation whatsoever let's tape it
up and then let's take it
all right
this is a good catch guys
so now we are going to transport the
boxes to the U.S fish and wildlife
service office of law enforcement in
Miami so that we can do more detail
examination and also ID the fins and
making sure that everything is
documented
it's a really big seizure
we've gone through two boxes so far out
of 18.
this is just the beginning
all right I got the search worn in hand
and we are headed over there to you guys
hopefully this bulk flow to
methamphetamine is sitting in this house
but I don't know we'll just have to wait
and see once we get in there
all right we have the main target
detained that's one threat down so we'll
go ahead and knock on this door
hopefully there's not another person in
there with weapons of any kind and we'll
uh start searching
[Music]
[Music]
outdoor sportify like that God I hope so
outdoor sportify like that God I hope so
come out
towards there from the back of the front
all right I'll say we're all clear
all right let me go figure out what's
going on
they made entry there are no other
people in there so we're going to go
ahead and start the search process
anything through that backside nothing
back there no nothing
he's got dope somewhere I mean I'm sure
once we start digging in here
oh here it is
big box full of dope
and yeah there's a bunch in there bags
filled with meth
big box of money in the back too that's
good
during the search of the residents we
found probably about 40 or 50 000 in
cash a loaded handgun and a cardboard
box that has multiple gallon bags filled
with meth uh very similar to those two
gallon size bags that we just took off
the traffic stop earlier
now we're in the process of getting
rooms labeled and getting some pictures
then we'll pick up all the evidence from
here and take it to our office with the
evidence that we seized on a traffic
stop
this is like a big ass bag of ice
I don't know how much math it is right
now we'll just have to wait and see once
we figure stuff out
but it's a good haul we're getting a
good chunk off the street today
foreign
we brought the shark fins back here to
the warehouse and we're just helping
fishing Wildlife process and go through
it
let's do this
let's start feeling number two this way
the shark fin trade it's a very
lucrative Market
approximately a 100 million sharks are
taken yearly to make the famous shark
fin soup
shark fin soup in Asia can go from a
hundred dollars to 400 600 of both
we have a mix of species some of them
fall into The Endangered Species Act and
they require permits to be exported
so far we have silky sharks
great hammerhead
this is a tiger shark this is a pectoral
fin
this shipment came in with no permits
and that's why make the entire shipment
illegal so this box is done so now we
can do let's get our total number on
that one box number one
in this shipment we have an approximate
total of 1400 pounds
it'll go for 500 a pound so this
shipment's worth approximately seven
hundred thousand dollars
we're looking at thousands of shark fins
this is the largest seizure I've ever
been a part of of working for CBP now
for 10 years
it's a sad day for conservation and for
sharks in general there's hundreds of
animals that were illegally obtained on
this shipment
however it's a good day for us because
it directly affects the revenue from
illegal surfing trade
[Music]
[Music]
so what we're doing is testing this to
see if it tests positive for
methamphetamine
[Music]
put just a little sample in here
this one should test blue
[Music]
so that's a positive test for
methamphetamine
the purchasers like big shards it makes
them feel like they're getting the best
stuff in the world but math is math so
they're each a kilo a piece there was 19
bags from the house and then two that we
seized on a traffic stop
all in all we got approximately 21 kilos
of methamphetamine worth approximately
105 000 on the street
along with the drugs we made two arrests
and we seized two handguns and
approximately sixty seven thousand
dollars in cash
I'm extremely happy anytime we can take
methamphetamine off the streets it's an
incredible day for law enforcement
[Music]